[Música]
bueno pues yo creo que ya después del
spoiler que me han hecho aquí
estos dos yo creo que ya sobró pero
bueno ya que me la tengo preparada está
esta presentación pues vamos allá a ver
que levanten la mano a aquellos que
hayan visto alguna película de indiana
jones
interesante bueno pues para los pocos
que no han visto una película de indiana
jones interna yo sé es un personaje
interpretado por el guaperas de harrison
ford que descubre siempre los tesoros
más increíbles y del que siempre se
enamora la chica más guapa de la
película claro está en fin sigue esa
parte quién no quiere descubrir un
tesoro oculto hace ya unos cuantos años
un grupo de camineros o de caminantes
porque también había camineras
decidió hacer una ruta un tanto especial
por esta zona
partieron de él con el permiso de los
cormoranes del embalse de molino de la
hoz y tomaron una vereda monte arriba a
lo largo del cauce del río guadarrama
empiezan a caminar y alguien pregunta
pero vosotros tenéis claro dónde vamos
y el listillo de turno tu sigue que es
por aquí continúan nuestros caminantes
empiezan las conjeturas y fantasías
porque han leído algo sobre una presa de
no saben cuándo a los de torrelodones
les contaban cuando eran pequeños que si
por aquí hay algo de los romanos los de
las rozas que si durante la guerra civil
pasaron cosas y los de galapagar que
aquí hay una cárcel secreta en fin
nuestros caminantes avanzan cuesta
arriba a lo largo del cauce del río
aunque estas alturas ya no pueden verlo
porque el río se ha quedado abajo allá
abajo encajado en la garganta granítica
del estrecho de la peña
de repente alguien dice
pero qué es eso de allí y el listillo
nada piedras como que nada como que
piedras si parece una muralla la emoción
acelera su paso y alarga sus zancadas
efectivamente allá abajo medio taponando
el río hay un murallón altísimo y
anchísimo y aunque está medio en ruinas
se arriesgan a bajar hasta él y desde la
cima a asomarse al lecho del río
guadarrama están a más de 50 metros del
lecho del río y las las vistas son de
vértigo y encima la vegetación tiene
todos los colores posibles que puede dar
el otoño
y entonces nuestros caminantes se
preguntan tan cerca de madrid puede
haber una maravilla así y que nadie o
casi nadie la conozca pues efectivamente
esa misma pregunta me dice yo la primera
vez que vi la presa del casco cómo es
posible que una maravilla así sea tan
poco conocida cuando yo la vi fue fue
para mí cómo descubrir la presa del
casco de las fuentes del nilo o la tumba
de tutankamón y por eso estoy aquí para
redescubrir este tesoro oculto durante
siglos para vosotros y con vosotros
porque efectivamente la presa del casco
es del siglo 18 lleva aquí más de dos
siglos construida
y casi nadie la conoce y ahora estaréis
preguntando
estaréis preguntando para qué queremos
una presa aquí en un paraje tan
escondido tan en medio de ninguna parte
pues muy sencillo para embalsar el cauce
del río guadarrama y desviar sus aguas
hacia un canal que llegase hasta sevilla
hasta sevilla si si habéis oído bien y
desde allí hasta el océano atlántico a
lo largo de más de 770 kilómetros que es
más que la distancia que hay entre irun
y finisterre recorriendo toda la cornisa
cantábrica
y bueno ahora os estáis preguntando para
qué queremos un canal pues para
transportar mercancías remolcadas desde
la orilla por animales de carga estos
animales iban atados a las barcazas
donde iba a la carga por unas maromas o
sirgas que eran unas cuerdas muy gruesas
y fuertes por eso este tipo de canal se
llama camino de sirga
si el canal del guadarrama se hubiera
construido habría de alguna manera
revolucionado el sistema de transporte
españa como el resto de europa apostó
por los canales fluviales y de hecho ya
había alguno
en fin pues como el canal bueno no os he
dicho que estamos en pleno reinado de
carlos tercero finales del siglo 18
es un rey que se ganó a pulso el apodo
de alcalde de madrid
todos sabemos que construyó el museo del
prado el jardín botánico el museo reina
sofía bueno el hospital 'san carlos y la
puerta de alcalá las cibeles neptuno e
incluso adoquinó muchas calles con
granito de esta zona pero es que además
los caminos eran muy precarios y por eso
necesitábamos un camino fluvial
necesitábamos un camino de sirga
y bueno como era tan importante manos a
la obra
la presa del casco es en realidad
dos muros está formada por dos muros
convergentes de un grosor de dos metros
80 aguas arriba y 3 metros y medio aguas
abajo todo ello reforzado con un sistema
de celdas rellenadas con materiales y
piedras y con contrafuertes para poder
soportar la presión del agua pero es que
este muro que veis aquí tiene 53 metros
de alto pero estaba diseñado para ser
una tener una altura de 93 metros habría
sido un poco más alto que el edificio
españa os imagináis construir en el
siglo 18 una mole así en medio de la
garganta de un río impresionante
y el muro que ya hemos dicho que está
formado con estos dos paramentos tiene
llegaría a haber tenido una longitud de
250 metros si hubiéramos alcanzado los
93 metros de altura entre ladera y
ladera de esta garganta del estrecho de
la peña para que os hagáis una idea el
puente de toledo no tiene más que 180
metros
en fin pues manos a la obra
él
el canal
tenía bueno no no os he dicho la cosa
que más me gusta del canal que es el
aliviadero no sé si se ve muy bien pero
este de viajeros en realidad un túnel de
50 metros de largo por
12 de alto y 8 de ancho por ahí pueden
pasar trenes de dos pisos de altura y
sobrados o gigantescos camiones de
mercancía
en fin
quien hizo este prodigio carlos lemus
carlos lemos
era un ingeniero
militar de origen francés con amplia
experiencia en otros canales y en
puertos porque incluso había diseñado el
paso de despeñaperros
carlos lemus se embarcó en este proyecto
tan caro pero necesitaba financiación
acudió al banco nacional de san carlos
el actual banco de españa- y también
contaba con el apoyo de carlos tercero
que
y dedicó hasta el uno y medio por ciento
de toda la plata que venía de américa
en fin
en noviembre de 1785 nuestro ingeniero
presenta el proyecto al banco para que
suelte la pasta pero
pocos días más tarde a nuestro nuestro
ingeniero aparece muerto en su casa en
extrañas circunstancias
tan extrañas que fue enterrado en
secreto es decir de noche y sin ningún
tipo de boato un señor tan importante
bueno sus hijos que eran ingenieros y
delineantes heredaron el proyecto pero
tuvieron que hacer todo el detalle
técnico de la obra
si el rey y el banco nacional tenían
tanto interés en una obra de esta
envergadura era porque pensaban obtener
pingües benefícios con el peaje que
pagará a la gente que usará este camino
fluvial esta carretera esta autopista
fluvial además de la utilización de
molinos y batanes con lo cual pensaban
recuperar ampliamente la inversión
y tan obviamente qué
y trajeron miles de personas a trabajar
entre jornaleros trajeron incluso
militares militares y además trajeron
prisioneros condenados a trabajos
forzosos bueno y de pasos a grabar una
pasta con los presos claro en fin
llevaban construida más de la mitad de
la presa hemos dicho los 53 metros y
varios kilómetros del canal cuando tras
fuertes lluvias que causaron graves
filtraciones en el paramento de granito
el 14 de mayo de 1799 una tormenta de
rayos truenos y centellas derribó parte
del paramento sur
de manera bueno fue de noche
afortunadamente y no hubo víctimas pero
nos podemos imaginar el tremendo susto
que se llevaron todos estos jornaleros
militares etcétera que vivían en chozas
en una especie de poblado de pioneros en
las inmediaciones de la obra
se intentó
y retomar el proyecto pero los
promotores estaban en la ruina y además
detectaron algunos fallos técnicos en el
diseño un siglo más tarde también
pensaron en construir el canal del
guadarrama cosa que nos llegó a hacerse
pero si también se pensó que en los
kilómetros construidos de canal podrían
utilizarse como acequias
y os voy a contar un secreto
durante la guerra civil española hay
crónicas orales que hablan que el canal
se utilizó como
carretera secreta para vehículos a motor
para ocultarse de los aviones de la
aviación control
en fin no os canso más si estoy aquí es
porque el canal del guadarrama y la
presa del casco además de su belleza su
belleza romántica de ruinosa
está en una ubicación impresionante
estamos cerca del camino imperial a el
escorial
estamos en la cuenca del curso medio del
río guadarrama y estamos en la falla de
torrelodones que es el primer escalón de
ascenso a la sierra de guadarrama por
eso la sociedad caminera del réal del
manzanares llevamos años luchando para
que nuestro canal y nuestra presa sean
declarados bien de interés cultural de
hecho prácticamente fue uno de nuestros
primeros objetivos cuando fundamos esta
asociación
en fin creemos que tanto el canal como
la empresa del conjunto forman un
importante patrimonio nacional de la
historia de nuestro país de manera que
ahora que conocéis la presa del casco y
el canal del guadarrama no dan ganas de
protegerlo pásalo
[Aplausos]